here's a question for all you type a
people out there have you ever worked so
hard for a dream job or a promotion that
you pushed yourself beyond your limits
and you sacrificed your health chloe
benjamin knows what that's like she went
from being an assistant to a new york
times best-selling author with her book
the immortalist it was a moment she
dreamed of so behind the scenes though
she was grappling with stress and
chronic migraines she ended up in the er
in a recent article for the cut she
wrote this about her physical breakdown
saying i had put my writing my ambition
and my success over not just my health
but my experience of life wow she joins
us now with her story and some advice
for a less stressful life chloe i'm so
glad to see you because i so related to
this story because i'm i i'm a big
believer i'm pushing through plowing
through you said that you did that
almost to the expense not almost to the
expense of your health when did you
realize okay i have a real problem here
and that i can't push through
well i think it's interesting because it
was a slow realization and in fact it
was um you know i was hearing these cues
from my body the body speaks through
pain yes um when when you're not
listening you know to anything else and
slowly i started to realize i could no
longer ignore those signals but i did
for a very long time but what were the
signals specific really pain speaking to
you pain yeah just increasing migraines
you know i was so grateful to go
on a book tour that was quite extensive
i was so honored that this book found a
wide audience but every time i did an
event i would get a migraine and i
didn't
listen to that until it was too late and
what does listen to your body really
mean well we hear this phrase listen to
your body and for me you know it it
became very granular it was
how am i holding my tension
how am i breathing i realized that i
held so much tension in my shoulders i
think a lot of us do and so i actually
put stickers around my house and when i
saw the sticker that was my cue to relax
my shoulders
i almost had this detective quality of
what makes my body feel good what makes
my body feel bad and and really getting
to know myself in that way so that my
body could trust my mind and my mind
could trust my body there's so much
pressure on people people put it on
themselves to push through that kind of
pain so on the one hand there's listen
to your body but on the other hand
there's we get this cultural message or
maybe you can tell me where you think it
comes from to push through can you trace
that back to some origin because tony
sometimes i think is it really that bad
is pain really that bad
i wonder about this too
well i think we live in a world in which
productivity is prized over almost
anything else and you know there's this
idea of grind culture right now you know
no days off push
and i think that can be so harmful
because it means that again we're
privileging our work over our experience
of life and why are we doing that and
how can we change it yeah so you said
you've changed you've changed i have
yeah how you live it it's taken a few
years to make those changes and honestly
i never thought i could i've been
ambitious and professed perfectionistic
since childhood and those qualities got
me to a place of success but they also
hurt me
so you know the way that i live is
totally different and one thing that i
hope might be helpful to others is an
idea of pacing so rather than waiting
until i finish a scene or a book or a
tour to rest i'm resting throughout the
day
you know i'll take a five minute break
to meditate i'll walk around the block
even just looking out the window for a
few minutes when i'm on a screen and
this way my energy moves like a wave
instead of building to a point of
collapse i can imagine younger people
particularly younger creative people
listening to you and saying it's very
easy for chloe to say this now because
she's already made it she wrote a
bestseller that's so true tony what do
you say to that
when you're starting out it's very
different when you're when you're still
trying to make it make it you're still
trying to push through right it is it's
true although when i look back i think
maybe i didn't have to do as much
touring as i did for the book to be
successful and maybe it's okay to say no
because when you say no what are you
saying yes to
that might be your health that might be
creating a way of working that's
sustainable because the thing is you
don't want to have one book that's a
success and then not be able to write or
promote for years so actually if you
know i think
maybe it's a fallacy that you have to
push and push and push until you make it
because then you crash i think it
definitely is maybe you can make it
saying yes to i like that yeah and maybe
you know you can make it
oh sorry that's okay
just finish it um you know maybe you can
do it in a more sustainable way okay i
think it's definitely true i'm gonna
read the immortalists thank you very
much
we'll be right back